foreign
sometimes
what do you want me to do what is it
that you want if you really want to do
something for me then stop making this
scene right now oh God
I'm leaving assess the situation and I'm
going
where are you going just leaving but
where
I have to return some videotapes
hello there it is as Perez I live in
this little box you call a television or
maybe it's a big box but welcome to RT
Essentials today we are discussing films
from one of my absolute favorite genres
films that fright and Delight with
suspense so intense It Cuts Like a Knife
but then leaves you in stitches you will
scream then you'll smile and then okay I
think you get it I'm talking about
horror comedies and these movies are
both scary and funny enough to hold
their own in either category now this
hybrid genre has been a beloved part of
mainstream Cinema since the silent ERA
with many considering the 1922 Gothic
classic one exciting night to be the
pioneering release but over the past
couple of decades horror comedies have
seen a meteoric rise in popularity
especially thanks to some of the
selections on this list so stick around
and find out which ones I'm talking
about these are the best horror comedies
of all time what we do in the shadows oh
sorry sorry
what hey what time is it
um we're going to have a flat meeting in
about 10 minutes 20. okay is it
what we do in the shadows is a
mockumentary style horror written and
directed by Jermaine Clement and
taikawatiti who also star in the leading
roles now follows a group of vampire
housemates living in Wellington New
Zealand as they try to cope with the
complexities of Modern Life argue about
trivial matters like doing the dishes
and they face off with a rival werewolf
gang now this film has all the
foundations of a classic horror suspense
monsters eerie music but let's be real
this is why TT and Clement were talking
about so of course it's gonna lean heavy
on the laughs and if if you are a fan of
Clemen in Flight of the Concords then
you're gonna love his character in this
film lotuslav the poker side note for
all the true horror fans out there
vladislav the poker is based on Vlad the
Impaler a real-life Romanian ruler from
the 15th century who may or may not have
indulged in some unorthodox methods of
warfare that ultimately earned him his
moniker now I'll spare you the gruesome
details but this is important because
Vlad the Impaler served as the
inspiration for Bram Stoker's novel
Dracula and without the novel Dracula
there is no film adaptation of Dracula
starring Gary Oldman as the count and
Gary oldman's performance in that film
directly inspired Clement's performance
in this film now although Clement
admitted that his version of Dracula was
far less quote successful and dashing
you're on camera what it's okay because
I know this guy is
very offensive words
we're talking about a bundle of sticks
chase this bundle of sticks where the
Wolves
but what we do in the shadows was
critically praised for its dark edgy
humor with the guardian calling it the
best comedy of the year it also spawned
in American television series version
with the same title that aired on FX in
2019 and is still going strong it's one
of my favorite shows of all time and
that is because like the vampires
themselves a good story is Immortal
ready or not I'm really sorry about all
this
true what they say the rich really are
different
I'll give you a 10 second Head Start
Daniel
now ready or not takes the classic
children's game Hide and Seek and it
raises the stakes as high as they can go
well maybe not as high as it can go
because squid game kind of did that but
this is like matter of life and death
kind of stakes Matt buttonelli open and
Tyler Gillette co-direct this edge of
your seat experience that follows Grace
a beautiful bride who has just happily
married the man of her dreams at his
family's luxurious estate and everything
is Picture Perfect there's just one itsy
bitsy catch her husband Mark's family
has this ritual that Grace must hide
from Midnight until dawn and avoid being
caught by her new in-laws seems innocent
enough grace even thinks so at first
that is until she realizes that Mark's
family has armed themselves with an
array of weapons including guns
crossbows even Aunt Helene grabs a giant
ax I mean the point is is that they mean
to kill Grace and now she must
desperately try to survive the night
sorry the
let me just quickly reboot doesn't just
call a [ __ ] police
man it says here that the car was
reported stolen I'm sorry but I have to
shut it down no what no what the [ __ ]
are you kidding me this film is honestly
such a wild ride and it is all the Goran
jump scares that you'd expect from a
horror but it also veers so far into the
lane of absurdity that you can't help
but laugh people are literally running
maniacally through this lavish castle of
a home soaked in blood getting their
heads blown off with antique pistols and
taking arrows to the face I mean it
reaches Tarantino levels of exaggerated
Gore and all the while Grace charges
through this chaos without ever changing
out of her wedding dress like a total
badass shout out to Samara weaving for
her epic performance in this one ready
or not received positive reviews from
critics with many praising the acting
script and Direction and Entertainment
Weekly wrote quote come for the
crossbows and watch weaving star be born
in real time stay for the socioeconomic
lessons and sweet sweet revenge well
said The Cabin in the Woods
okay baby let's see some boobies
show us the goods
does it really matter if we see we're
not the only ones watching gotta keep
the customer satisfied
you understand what's at stake here
having horror movies taught us
trips too
or I mean do we need to watch the Evil
Dead in Friday the 13th to remind us of
why we shouldn't actually those are
exactly the movies director writer Drew
Goddard was poking fun at when he made
the cabin in the woods now it's a story
of Five College friends who arrive at a
remote Forest cabin for a little
vacation unaware of the true Horrors
that await them now as you've already
predicted one by one the youths fall
victim to the horrors that inhabit these
dark woods but something much larger is
at play here unbeknownst to the
sacrificial friend group in the cabin
there are two scientists manipulating
the entire ordeal from their underground
laboratory Now The Cabin in the Woods
checks every possible box on the long
list or horror tropes starting with the
characters themselves you got the jock
type the sexy cheerleader type the
stoner the scholar and of course the
Virgin now obviously these choices are
deliberately on the nose and the
filmmakers themselves have described
this as a quote serious critique of what
they love and don't love about horror
movies and one of the most enjoyable and
Brilliant aspects of this movie is that
it somehow manages to be an entirely
predictable and entirely unpredictable
experience it's so strange
I'm actually rooting for this girl
so much heart
you think of all the
pain and the
Punk tequila is my lady my lady come on
in guys come on in come on in you're
welcome tequila from Darkness there is
light now to avoid spoilers I won't dive
much cheaper into the plot but I will
say it is a must-see don't take my word
for it listen to what audiences and
critics have said like the New Yorker
who wrote the filmmakers are less
interested in providing a slow build up
to their frights then in splattering the
cliches of the form in funny spirited
ways also it's worth watching just for
the merman yes I said merman and that's
all I'm gonna say about it Young
Frankenstein
what knockers oh
thank you doctor
oh that's all right
it doesn't get much more classic than
Young Frankenstein written and directed
by Mel Brooks and starring Gene Wilder
the icon who also co-wrote the script
with Brooks now Gene plays respected
medical lecturer Dr Frederick
Frankenstein who learns that he has
inherited his Infamous grandfather's
estate in Transylvania which is in
Romania which is also where Vlad the
Impaler AKA Dracula is from just making
sure that we're all paying attention
here I feel like I should have like a
chalkboard anyways when Dr Frankenstein
arrives at the castle he begins to
recreate his grandfather's experiments
with the help of his servants Igor Inga
and the Fearsome Frau blucher but
complications arise after Dr
Frankenstein creates a monster of his
own
penny for your thoughts
marriageable aren't you
Nipper neck
[Music]
all right
seven has always been my lucky number
come over here you hot monster
now while working together on this
satirical Western and Blazing Saddles
Brooks noticed that Wilder was writing
notes on a legal pad with the words
Young Frankenstein written at the top
this piqued Brooks's interest and soon
Gene pitched Brooks's concept for this
movie adding that it would be his dream
if he would write the movie with him and
direct it now obviously Brooks agreed
and what ensued was the making of what
many consider to be one of the greatest
parodies ever Young Frankenstein was a
box office hit grossing over 86 million
on a budget of just under 3 million but
the True Legacy of this film can't be
Quantified Newsweek called it quote the
most cinematically assured coherent and
tasteful of Brooks's films and The New
Yorker wrote that quote Wilder's
hysteria seems perfectly natural you
never question what's driving him to it
his fits are lucid and total and
additionally Young Frankenstein was
selected for preservation in the Library
of Congress by the national film
registry and even Brooks himself
considers this to be his quote finest
film as a writer director which is High
Praise even if that praise comes from
himself
Tucker and Dale Versus Evil
you okay
keeping the parody train rolling is
Tucker and Dale Versus Evil a story
about two scruffy Pals yes named Tucker
and Dale who take a backwoods vacation
now again don't go to the woods because
bad things always happen there and for
Tucker and Dale their little getaway
takes a bloody turn when ignorant
college students mistake them for a pair
of murderous Hillbillies turns out they
had the wrong Hillbillies or I mean did
they watch the movie folks I am not in
the business of spoiling us what I will
say is that much like The Cabin in the
Woods this film plays on horror tropes
there's plenty of outrageous and
laughable Gore like that one accident
that may or may not involve a wood
chipper also someone impaling themselves
with their own spear shout out to our
boy Vlad from Transylvania and a man who
may or may not accidentally shoot
himself in the head again I'm not giving
too much away here you got cabin and
woman set on fire car crashes Sawmills
tea induced asthma attacks that cause
convulsions that then lead to someone
falling out of a window to their death
again I'm not revealing anything go back
to hell where you belong freak
don't use that
bro
now Tucker and Dale vs Evo premiered at
Sundance in January of 2010 and it
received a limited theatrical release in
the US made on a budget of only 5
million it was clearly not going to pack
the same commercial punch as a big
budget horror release but that didn't
stop this film from being a critical
success Roger Ebert wrote that students
with a little movie glossary may find it
funny how carefully Tucker and Dale
Works its way through upended cliches
Jennifer's Body do you know how hard it
is to make it as an indie band these
days
so many of us
they're all so cute and it's like if you
don't get on Letterman or some good
soundtrack you're screwed okay Satan is
our only hope
we're in League with the Beast now and
we have to make a really big impression
on them and to do that we're going to
have to butcher you and bleach you and
then dirt care is going to wear your
face relax
the rest is gonna happen though
Jennifer's Body was written by Diablo
Cody who first rose to prominence after
publishing a memoir entitled candy girl
a year in the life of an unlikely
stripper Cody then went on to win an
Oscar a bafta an independent Spirit
award and a writer's Guild of America
award for writing the film Juno her
debut as a screenwriter point is Cody is
a badass and expertly Pen this hyper
stylized story about a high school girl
named Jennifer who gets possessed by a
demon and now turns her hungry eye on a
guy who never set a chance with her
before now while evil Jennifer satisfies
her vampiric cravings for human flesh
with the school's male population her
nerdy friend needy learns what's
happening and vows to put an end to the
madness and Carnage so much Carnage now
at its core Jennifer's Body is an
examination of two unlikely high school
friends and the glaring dichotomies of
their existences but it also satirizes
small town life and similar to The Cabin
in the Woods plays on the personality
type tropes that we discussed earlier
cheerleaders jocks Band Geeks film Buffs
I'm kidding no film Buffs were harmed in
the duration of this movie I can't say
the same for screen though but what they
didn't know is that she hasn't been a
virgin since junior high it all makes
sense now read this if the human
sacrifice is impure the result may still
be attained but the demon will forever
reside in the soul of the victim she
must forever feed on flesh to sustain
the demon
okay she's eating boys they like make
her really pretty and glowy and her hair
looks amazing and then when she's hungry
she's weak and cranky and ugly I mean
like ugly for her now Jennifer's Body
was a total flop upon its release but
interestingly enough has been
reevaluated in recent times and is
actually now considered a cult classic
many see it as a female empowered
sleeper hit that was simply ahead of its
time and it now shows up on list of
great horror movies directed and written
by women additionally the film has been
praised in countless articles with
headlines like this one from Vice saying
Jennifer's Body would kill if it came
out today pun intended American Psycho
look at that subtle of white coloring
it even has a watermark
something wrong
Patrick
you're sweating ah the film that made me
rethink my skincare routine and my love
for Huey Lewis and the News I'm of
course talking about American Psycho
written and directed by Mary Herron and
based on the novel of the same name Now
set in New York City in the 80s
Christian Bale is Patrick Bateman a
young and handsome investment banker who
happens to Moonlight as a brutal serial
killer now it's all fun and games for
Bateman that is until a private
investigator named Donald Kimball Willem
Dafoe starts asking questions about Paul
Allen a colleague of Bateman who has
mysteriously disappeared now if you've
seen the film you'll understand
immediately what happened to poor Paul
Allen it was a watermark on that
business card he just had to have that
darn Watermark I mean that's what did
him in
he's been compared to Elvis Costello but
I think Huey has a far more bitter
cynical sense of humor
oh yeah yes Alan why are the copies of
the style section on the play do you
have a dog a little chow or something
no Helen is that a raincoat yes it is
American Psycho is one of the more
comedically understated selections on
this list so unapologetically dark and
disturbing that the satire might get
lost on the average person but we aren't
your average Cinema Joe's here and
moments like the one I touched on before
where Bateman is literally losing his
mind over Alan having a better business
card than him are undeniably ridiculous
and funny American Psycho received
polarizing reviews with many praising
and many criticizing Belle's performance
but there's no denying the cult status
for this one and the lasting power of
its many notable moments that have now
become some of the most popular memes on
the internet An American Werewolf in
London my asleep now awake or what
I realize I don't look so hot David but
I thought you'd be glad to see me
David
you're hurting my feel
hurting your feelings
has it occurred to you it might be
unsettling to see you arise from the
grave to visit me sorry to be upsetting
you David An American Werewolf in London
lends itself primarily to the horror
genre many even consider it to be one of
the greatest horror movies ever and will
often declare it as such without
bothering to mention that it's also a
comedy and they're not wrong because
this film is genuinely terrifying and
offers plenty of suspense it also
contains graphic violence that is
realistic enough to make you feel uneasy
well as realistic as a movie about
werewolves could be but the team behind
this film also happens to be responsible
for some of the most successful comedies
ever so of course there are plenty of
hilarious moments like when the
protagonist David wakes and finds
himself naked in a wolf cage at the
London Zoo I mean don't you just hate it
when that happens everyone's looking at
you like you're crazy
Must Die David Kessler
[Music]
David this is Harry Berman
and his fiancee Judith Browns hello
hello and these gentlemen are Alf Ted
and Joseph can't say we're pleased to
meet you Mr Kessler okay where was I oh
yeah David and his friends Jack are
American college students backpacking
through Britain where they are suddenly
attacked by a large wolf now David
survives with just a bite but Jack
doesn't fare so well maybe that's
because David ran away immediately and
left Jack to fight the wolf alone solid
friend David I mean remind me to never
invite you backpacking actually don't
ever go in the woods note to self
anyways as werewolf folklore has taught
us a werewolf bite means a werewolf life
and David literally becomes an American
Werewolf in London now the film became
an instant classic and won the first
ever Oscar for best makeup it also
spawned a sequel American Werewolf in
Paris which released in 1997. slither
hey
[ __ ]
writer director James Gunn now known for
the Guardians of the Galaxy franchise
made his directorial debut with slither
a film that pays homage to horror
classics like John Carpenter is a thing
and David Cronenberg Shivers and The
Brood set in the fictional small town of
wheelsey South Carolina an alien
organism has infiltrated the community
and now threatens to devour all life on
Earth and that is my very PG explanation
of the plot I'm leaving out the parts
about said aliens impregnating women who
then swell up to the size of a small bus
and then explode releasing an army of
slimy slugs that then like enter
people's mounts and take control of
their brains and bodies it's all
disgusting and absolutely hilarious like
a horror comedy should be it's okay
Grant
you're just stickers off
you're just sick
we're just here
to take you to get some
right now
and I'm gonna stay by you
just like I swore I would
For Better or Worse
the film was a box office failure and it
sparked controversy over its
similarities to the 1986 horror Comedy
Night of the Creeps but gun was very
deliberate in referencing the B movies
of the 1980s and controversy aside
critics were all about it with the New
Yorkers speaking my language and calling
it quote a delightfully disgusting comic
horror film get out
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
get out
oh sorry man get out yo yeah
last but certainly not least is writer
director Jordan peels get out Daniel
kaluya plays Chris and Allison Williams
plays Rose a young interracial couple
who have reached the meet the parent
stage of their relationship but as we
learn from writing or not hanging with
your partner's family can prove to be
problematic or horrifying and after
Chris agrees to a weekend getaway at
Rose's parents estate he's LED down a
rabbit hole of increasingly unsettling
events and uncovers A Dark Truth he
never could have imagined and see this
is what I came up with they're probably
abducting black people brainwashing them
and making them slaves or sex slaves not
just regular slaves but sex slaves
see I don't know if it's the hypnosis
that's making them slaves or whatnot
but all I know is they already got two
brothers we know and it could be a whole
bunch of Brothers they got already
what's the next move
[Laughter]
now peel is a master of suspense taking
a page from the book of Hitchcock but
there was a lot of debate as to whether
this film was meant to be funny or not
so much so that peel felt the need to
weigh in and humorously tweeted quote
get out is a documentary but then he
further explained in interviews that
quote it's not a movie that can be put
into one genre box what really matters
are the film's messages and themes now
genre drama aside get out draws on a
very specific type of visceral Terror
and peel brilliantly subverts and
reimagines many classic horror cliches
and does so with a wicked sense of humor
so it's not surprising that the film was
a commercial and critical Triumph and
that peel won an Oscar for best original
screenplay there you have it my friends
our selections for the best horror
comedies of all time and of course there
are many others we didn't have time to
discuss but fear not we have plenty of
new episodes of RT Essentials coming
your way so I am sure we will get there
soon thank you again so much for tuning
and I'm Nas Perez and now if you'll
excuse me I have to return some
videotapes
[Applause]
[Music]